I think when I first got into any
position of like presenting my ideas in
public at first getting dog piled by
people and being accused called all
these names that aren't true it's like
it did bother me I think it's a natural
human reaction to be bothered when
people hate you for me it seems like
over time it's just been this uh it's
just kind of this numbing effect it just
doesn't matter anymore so are you that
numb now to it or did you immediately
jump in and you didn't care was there
any kind of similar process yeah I think
for a lot of people there probably is a
process of learning how to deal with all
the hate um I got over it very very
quickly maybe it was unnatural I also
like I said I was never really involved
in politics so I didn't I'm like I'm
kind of like an outsider and I just come
in I'm sharing videos and these people
are hating on me and I'm just like like
I don't know what you're doing I don't
care about you I don't care what you say
I know what I'm doing is right